ever wonder why most people borrow money
the way they do they use loans and
credit cards without giving it much
thought
want it now but don't have all the money
for it hey no problem
I'll just put it on this little piece of
plastic and it's mine buy now pay later
has become a way of life for the normal
American right now the average total
household credit card debt is over
fifteen thousand dollars and the average
student loan debt is about thirty
thousand dollars that's a lot of money
to pay back and that doesn't even count
the interest later in this class you're
going to learn why credit cards and car
loans are such a terrible idea but first
we need to ask a question how did we get
here let's take a quick look at the
evolution of the credit industry in
America before 1917 buying things on
credit was extremely rare that's because
there were laws preventing lenders from
charging high enough interest rates that
meant lenders couldn't make much money
by offering loans to working Americans
so they didn't bother with it sure there
were small-time loan sharks who took
advantage of broke scared and desperate
people but these were shady businesses
and the high interest rates they charged
were totally illegal jump ahead to 1920
World War one had ended and the consumer
demand for big-ticket manufactured
products skyrocketed around that time
lawmakers were trying to shut down the
illegal loan sharking industry so they
relaxed the credit laws and made it
profitable for respectable banks to
offer loans and what do you get when you
mix consumer demand for stuff and the
legalization of personal loans well in
the 1920s you got the birth of the
American credit industry then a little
bit later at the tail end of the 20s and
into the 30s the Great Depression was
raging the government relaxed lending
laws even more to help banks stay
profitable then moving into World War
two the economy improved a lot because
the war created a ton of new jobs after
the war the soldiers came home the
economy was in a lot better shape and
the lending laws were still relaxed that
pretty much set the stage for the birth
of the credit card in the 1950s debt was
becoming easier and more social
acceptable for the consumer and it was
more profitable for the lenders it was a
perfect storm the credit Monster has
grown like crazy since then in the past
50 or 60 years debt has gone from
something people were a little ashamed
of to something that's totally normal in
our culture banks keep coming up with
all new and different ways to get our
money everything from high interest
rates to a million different little fees
that pick our pockets and we as a
society have become so addicted to debt
that we still get excited when we're
approved for a credit card we think
hooray
I've been given the opportunity to lose
all my money and spend my life in debt
I'm so lucky
the bottom line is that a lot of people
you think look wealthy are completely
broke a big house nice car and flashy
jewelry may look great on the outside
but most of the time these days it just
means that the mailbox is filled with
outrageous bills and that the house is
filled with unbelievable stress about
how to pay for them this is not the
American Dream it's a trap but there's a
better way a way to have everything you
need a whole lot of what you want and a
legacy you'll be proud to leave to your
kids someday that's the kind of stuff
we're going to cover throughout this
class